[Musique]
c'est l'heure du café d'après-midi pour
jean-louis schwarz de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
sa conjointe annie savoure le début de
la soirée tu t'es pris un tueur de reins
très bien le couple vite à distance
depuis dix ans il habite à montréal elle
à nantes en france en octobre
les deux amoureux ont déposé une
première demande pour cannes y soit
autorisé à venir rejoindre jean-louis au
canada je n'ai jamais malgré l'envoi
d'une deuxième demande en novembre ils
sont toujours sans nouvelles du
ministère fédéral de l'immigration qui
gère le programme destiné à réunir les
couples qui ont été séparés par la
fermeture de la frontière les certitudes
perdure depuis cinq mois
la moindre des choses serait au moins de
dire bon bah on vous veut pas ou au
contraire on vous veut mais une réponse
aurait été la bienvenue
le ministère de l'immigration indique 28
mille demandes ont été déposées entre la
mise en place du programme en octobre et
la fin janvier
il affirme être en mesure de répondre à
80 % des requêtes dans le délai de 14
jours ouvrables qui s'est lui même fixé
un demandeur sur cinq doit donc attendre
plus longtemps
on allait poser dix neuf acteurs lors de
la fermeture de la frontière il ya un an
karine cloutier une montréalaise a été
séparée de son conjoint crise qui habite
au vermont ils pensaient être réunies
pour noël des jolis semaines se sont
accumulés jusqu'au 23 décembre où l'on
sait faire
votre dossier pas d'un système j'ai été
complètement détruites des failles
horrible le ministère de l'immigration a
finalement retrouvé leur dossier et
crise a pu rejoindre karine à montréal à
la mi janvier
trois mois après le dépôt de leur
demande j'ai l'impression que mon mur de
briques que j'avais en daim vie s'est
complètement écroulé et le fait qu'un
bon enfant entre temps jean louis et
annie poursuivre leur conversation par
vidéo-conférence
c'est pas la chaleur d'une présence
c'est pas la douceur d'avoir quelques
âmes l'horloge fait tic-tac c'est qu'on
n'a plus autant d'années devant nous
comme derrière nous donc c'est stressant
c'est déprimant il ya des jours vraiment
on trouve ça vraiment difficile ils
espèrent que leur dossier n'est pas
tombé entre deux chaises et attendent
toujours que le gouvernement fédéral se
manifeste ici olivier bastin radio
canada montréal